[Music]
for two weeks each year these giant
colorful lanterns float along korea's
namgang river turning it into a
kaleidoscope of light and color
[Applause]
the jinju namgang lantern festival takes
place in jinju south korea annually each
autumn season
[Applause]
a variety of colorful lanterns depicting
national treasures and the cultural
heritage of korea float along the
numgong river and visitors can take boat
rides for a closer look
in addition to the vibrant lanterns
there are live performances of music
fountain displays and of course no
festival is complete without fireworks
the origin of this lantern festival
dates back to the 1500s when the people
of jinju would light lanterns wishing
for the safe return of their family
members during the japanese invasion
today the festival continues in memory
of those soldiers who died serving their
country
visitors to the festival are welcome to
write their own wishes on lanterns and
either hang them in the exhibit tunnel
or float them down the river
[Music]